[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
welt und meine lieben freunde wir haben
heute so unfassbar viel auf unserer
to-do-liste dass wir gar nicht lange
zeit verlieren dürfen denn zuallererst
runden die kommentare geschrieben luca
diese trauminsel von dir das ist
eigentlich eine trauminsel das ist
eigentlich meine trauer insel denn wir
haben wir vorne unsere kirche die wir
anlässlich der ganzen verstorbenen
kritik diese kirche hier haben wir
anlässlich der verstorbenen tiere auf
unsere tier insel hier gebaut von daher
müssen wir eigentlich auch aufgrund der
tatsache weil wir hinten den friedhof
stehen haben die ganze tier insel
umbenennen von trauminsel zu trauer
insel hier vorne ist ja der friedhof
also das wird mir einmal geschrieben
also das jetzt nicht mehr die trauminsel
sondern die trauer insel dann nächste
sache die mir geschrieben wurde dann
muss ich mal ganz kurz für das bildchen
setzen die sache hat nämlich etwas mit
unserer strandhaus wer da helfen zu tun
ist sieht wirklich aus das wird sie an
der seite brennen das aber nur ein so
feuerstelle mir wurde auf jeden fall
geschrieben luca du hast bei den
gemälden irgendwie drei mal das gleiche
scheiß obstschalen gemälde hängen
welcher mensch hat drei mal die gleichen
obst schalen als bewährt generell ob
zahlen als bild von der schau ich mir
das mal ganz groß an ich weiß ehrlich
gesagt nicht ich weiß was er meint von
daher würde ich sagen nehmen wir dieses
gemälde mal weg setzt nie wieder die
blöcke hin und haben dann hier das
gemälde das ist kunst und dann würde ich
sagen wir auch noch mal die obstschale
hier oben weg da können wir auch mal
hier fordern eben die beiden blöcke
hinsetzen und haben wir jetzt haben
auf jeden fall also da haben jetzt auch
hier drei verschiedene gemälde
beziehungsweise generell fünf
verschiedene gemälde und das wo ich mich
gerade befinde soll auch das ziel für
die heutige episode sein denn meine
lieben freunde wir kümmern uns heute mal
wieder so ein bisschen qualität echt
schön aus so klar die fackeln müssen weg
und hier kann man dann nach unten gucken
das wollte ich noch hier machen
allerdings werden wir jetzt heute das
tut mir auch geschrieben luca der bambus
wächst das da musst du fäden darüber
packen ja was soll wenn er wächst dann
soll er halt ein bisschen höher werden
allerdings das heutige thema meine
lieben freunde wir gehen endlich mal
wieder zurück in die hölle
ich muss eigentlich aebischer sagen
ich denke dass es nicht so episch werden
wird wie ich gerade gesagt habe
allerdings müssen wir eine menge quatsch
holen was mir jedoch auch noch in die
kommentare geschrieben wurde war luca
hier unten der akquise hat sich ja alles
falsch gemacht was man damit falsch
machen kann
da muss chris martin darum die sache ist
allerdings dass wir dafür in das ozon
moment müssen und da müssen wir generell
auch noch hin denn wir brauchen noch
glas für unseren unterwassertunnel und
der mine kartstrecke wachsen wir
brauchen kein glas wenn wir noch
gebrauchen die steine um das wasser dann
aus dem tunnel raus zu locken auf jeden
fall müssen wir dazu halte in unserer
ozeane monument gehen und da ist halt
das problem dass ich dafür noch nicht so
richtig vor bin deswegen falls die tipps
dafür hat
[Musik]
hier so abgebaut ähnlich funktioniert
nicht richtig
schreibt mir gerne tipps fürs ozean
monument für die nächste folge und in
die kommentare und wie ich ein
aggregator abbauen denn der da unten
er will eben noch nicht so ganz mit auf
jeden fall das erste mal ganz gut du die
ganzen sachen die mir geschrieben wurden
ein bisschen hier eure ganzen kommentare
man hier jetzt hier an staaten dass ihr
auch wisst ihr kommen jetzt kurzzeitig
obsidian abbaue
[Musik]
das habt ihr nicht gesehen was er
allerdings gesehen habe ist dass ich mit
zehn obsidian geholt habe und zu beginn
der tablets habe ich auch schleims
gefunden und habe mir neun schreiben
werde von den zsc lions geholt die sind
nämlich irgendwie hier forderte sport
ich weiß nicht warum wir hatten ja schon
mal einen kleinen stein den ich gar
nicht behalten wollten allerdings leider
dies bond ist allerdings ist diese
fläche hier wohl irgendwie groß genug so
dass dort slime schleim spawnen und das
ist irgendwie passiert und die
schleimhäute sind eigentlich auch ganz
geil weil die benötigen wir für einen
die wir uns jetzt endlich machen können
um dann mal irgendwie tiere an stars zu
holen um keine ahnung was zu machen
das ist also sehr sehr sehr sehr geil
allerdings habe ich mir diese zehn
obsidian in erster linie einfach mal
geholt denn das habe ich ja schon der
letzten folge gesagt ich möchte mir ein
zweites ob sie die jahren portal also
den müssen wir auch noch mal zurück
holen
da wird mir auch einige sind die
kommentare geschrieben wie ich denen
anscheinend irgendwie wieder
zurückverwandeln kann zu einem normalen
will ja irgendwie mit einem goldenen
apfel oder irgendwie sowas keine ahnung
genau die sache ist allerdings dass wir
uns erstmal auf die sache mit dem
obsidian jetzt ein bisschen
konzentrieren denn ich möchte im netz wo
wir gleich halt rein gehen werden dass
obsidian nehmen und damit ein zweites
portal bauen.de da kann man irgendwie
schneller vorankommen als in der
eigentlichen minecraft welt und das geht
wohl nur mit einem anderen portal dass
man da wieder rauskommt und so nämlich
dazu ein bisschen gelesen dass wenn wir
gleich alles machen ich bereite mich
jetzt allerdings erst mal kurz darauf
vor
so ich bin fertig ausgerüstet und ihr
seht auch schon unten ich habe mir nun
zum ersten mal eine wir pilze route und
einen sattel mitgenommen denn damit
können wir wohl auf den hier fehlen
immer noch die seerosenblätter kann mir
das jemand in die kommentare schreiben
das jetzt nicht vergessen damit können
nicht zum ersten mal auf einem
wildschwein oder wie auch immer die
heißen reiten allerdings bewegen wir uns
nun erstmal zurück ich finde diesen ort
so verrückt es hat sich alles so krass
war
ich muss bis inc ok job ich finds immer
noch sehr furchteinflößend hier zu sein
auch in unserem komischen weg hier hoch
ins portal
na ja auch ich habe mir auf jeden fall
einen wir pilze routen start mitgenommen
und auch einen sattel so dass ich auf
den schweinchen über die lava reiten
kann
das soll heute allerdings keine privaten
denn das hier hat heute prio die quartz
blöcke und darauf müssen uns jetzt
erstmal ein bisschen konzentrieren von
der euch ist meine ganz kurze time lab
[Musik]
ich habe dir nicht angeguckt ich habe in
riehl talk nicht angeguckt so alle
sachen noch da glaube ich hoffe ich
keine ahnung wie viel leben ich hatte
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht wissen also
ständig ohne die kommentar recht tröste
mich jetzt mal ganz schnell neu
ausfahren noch ein bisschen quarz und
dann will ich sagen sie wir uns wieder
wenn ich so ein komisches tier gefunden
habe mit dem über die la bereiten können
[Musik]
ich glaube ich habe euch die szene
gerade einfach mal angelassen mit musik
oder so jetzt ist ja alles wegen ein
bisschen zu komisch ich weiß dass mein
portal irgendwo dahinten ist
ist sie das jetzt machen das machen wir
jetzt warum wir
ich habe ja nicht mehr reden halten wir
machen jetzt das warum ich das
wetterportal warum ich das auch die
gerne mitgenommen habe
denn ich möchte ja mehr hier vorne jetzt
auch mal ein zweites netter portal
machen ich habe irgendwo mal gewesen
dass man im netz
unfassbar schnell treffen kann deutlich
schneller als in der normalen welt
deswegen habe ich mir hier so ein paar
ressourcen mitgenommen und werde jetzt
einfach mal hier vorne ein portal
hinsetzen und dann werden wir jetzt mal
schauen wo wir rauskommen
[Musik]
in meiner welt
chillig bruder
ich wollte auch ein netter entkommen
weil mir das zu viel wurde mit den
ganzen mops und wo es baulich also in
die richtung habe ich das was auf jeden
fall blockiert allerdings kommt von hier
vorne ja auch noch was er sich leute
erst mal für euch ein bisschen aus ich
weiß nicht ob ich erhöhe wir sind
allerdings war vorher als wir hier von
aufgestiegen sind aus dem portal lava
und wir haben ja auch redstone also wir
sind anscheinend irgendwie auf einer
relativ tiefen höhe und haben hier
vielleicht ja auch irgendwie diamanten
die sache ist allerdings dass ich den
rest jetzt erstmal unterliegen lasse das
eisen ist mir relativ egal davon habe
ich viel zuviel schon zu hause
ich möchte einfach nur verdammten
ausgang finden ich dachte kommen
irgendwo oben raus bei einem dschungel
oder irgendwie sowas wäre halt ultras
gewesen allerdings nehme ich hier vorne
jetzt noch mal eben kurz das eisen mit
das können wir immer ganz gut gebrauchen
und dann suchen wir uns sitzt vorne
einfach mal ausgang
ich würde auch sagen ich finde jetzt
einfach mal hoch die sache ist dass hier
gar keine mops am start sind
also ich weiß nicht was daran liegt dass
wir diesen unter wasser
wir sind unter wasser
scheißegal ich kenne ich keine luft mehr
lukas schnell zurückgestellt zurück
gleich zurück ich muss irgendwie hier
rauskommen ich werde jetzt mal hier in
die andere richtung probieren also davon
ist ja unser portal
ich weiß nicht was passiert wäre hätte
tatsächlich auch
schlichter hatten schlechter ausgehen
können und wo bin ich jetzt mein gott
ich habe die luft herum entdeckt als ich
sie zumindest den himmel wo die sonne
auf oder sie geht auf mein gott meine
lieben freunde der mond geht dort hinten
runter ich habe keine ahnung wo wir sind
ich sehe nur die insel ich sehe da vorne
die insel wir sehen ganz hinten am
horizont etwas
ich werde jetzt erst mal dort hinten hin
schwimmen und dann schauen wir mal ob
wir das irgendwie hier auskennen
ich bin todes am schwitzen ich zeige
euch das mal ganz schon manchmal eben
kurzen foto hier vorne und blende euch
das jetzt hier ein
so sieht das hier vorne aus wenn ich
meine maus man also man unter armen an
der maus also schaut euch das mal an was
sich europa kommt es eben einmal
aufatmen
ich bin total nervös dass da hinten ist
kann ich auch noch nicht so richtig
erkennen immer ganz gut unterwegs bin
jetzt einfach mal nach vorne ich bin auf
jeden fall erstmal froh darüber dass wir
an der oberfläche sind ich bin froh
darüber dass wir 'ne menge bekommen
haben ich bin zwar gestorbene blogger
eine menge level verloren allerdings
habe ich trotzdem wieder 20 level
ich habe locker 46 quartz das reicht
erstmal für so ein bisschen von der
zweiten etage und vor allem haben wir 22
diamanten bekommen
um also ein paar sachen zu reparieren
war ich hier schon mal ne oder ich hab
keine ahnung wo wir sind ich gehe hier
vorne jetzt erst mal kurz an land und
dann schauen wir uns hier erst mal ein
bisschen um die sache ist dass ich
irgendwo gelesen habe ich weiß jetzt
nicht genau ob es stimmt aber dass man
im netz also in der hölle wo wir gerade
waren gegen die zehnmal so schnell reißt
wie in der eigentlichen welt das heißt
wenn wir im netz
irgendwie zehn blöcke gehen ist das so
wie wenn wir in unserer welt hier an der
oberwelt 100 blöcke weit gehen und wir
sind extrem weit gelaufen das hat ja in
der tat gesehen
einzig mir einerseits die sachen
gefahren haben und auf der anderen seite
wo ich dann gestorben bin und dann
nochmal euch die teils eingebildet habe
wie ich zu meinen sachen zurück gelaufen
bin
wir haben auf jeden fall eine menge
schafe wir haben eine menge schweine es
sieht doch alles ziemlich hohl ich ja
eigentlich aus ich noch mal ganz kurz
eben bisschen mehr holz es bringt
eigentlich gar nichts weil ich habe
schon holz und wir müssen ja immer dem
weg nach hause finde ich weiß allerdings
auch nicht ob ich gerade richtig laufe
wir haben unser laufen mal ganz schnell
nach oben schauen in die kiste wir haben
hier immer nur schwachsinn drinnen
federball 2 was soll ich mit federball
zwei degas allerdings weiß ich halt auch
nicht wie ich von hier also von dem
aussenposten jetzt zurückkommen soll zu
meiner spawn insel und meiner trauer in
sondern zum leuchtturm und zu meinem
portal schwer da unten kommen auch immer
mehr leute die mich angreifen wollen
aber die mit denen kann ich sie auf dann
vielleicht auch ein bisschen weh die
sache ist allerdings dass ich an der
stelle jetzt ist das uld dschungel ist
da hinten also wenn ich jetzt real talk
den dschungel entdeckt habe dann wäre es
die beste folge aller zeiten
also ich weiß nicht ob ihr das willst
aber den dschungel meinung des klägers
das seltenste was es gibt und das wäre
so unfassbar brutal geil weil ich das
wäre unfassbar ist wenn wir jetzt den
dschungel entdeckt hätten in dem
dschungel gibt's dschungel tempel es
gibt ganz viele sachen die wir nun
dschungel kriegen katzen und so weiter
und so fort allerdings so sein
[Musik]
immer diese pseudo dschungel mit den
pilzen pilze ich weiß auch ehrlich
gesagt gar nicht am start in die
richtige richtung laufen ich laufe jetzt
einfach weiter erinnert welche mir
sicher dass es hier ist allerdings würde
ich an der stelle des heutigen videos
auch beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
ihr irgendwie schon länger teil dieser
ganzen minecraft mit luca projektreise
seid dann schreibt mir gern haben wir
hier das schaf von oben auf jeden fall
entspannt
bin ich blöd oder haben wir hier das
schaf form das schwein vom ertrinken
gerettet
es hat auch so ähnlich aus oder ich weiß
es nicht ich will auch ehrlich gesagt
jetzt nicht mehr weiterlaufen nicht also
noch dass ich mich komplett verlauf und
eigentlich andere richtung muss also
freunde wenn ihr wisst anhand irgendwie
von wo ich von meinem portal hingelaufen
bitte nimm netter und wo ich jetzt raus
gekommen bin und das portal wie ich hoch
gesprungen bin und wenn ihr das
irgendwie zuordnen können schreibt mir
gerne in die kommentare in welche
himmelsrichtung nicht laufen soll
soll ich jetzt glaube ich süden hier ist
norden weil die sonne ja hier so ihren
bestand hat wo soll ich ihn laufen
schreibt mir unten in die kommentare
freuen wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
einen daumen runter video da abonniert
meinen kanal und klickt auf die glocke
wenn ihr neue videos nicht verpassen
wollte ich fand die episode sehr geil
ich wollte zwar eigentlich die zweite
etage meiner villa bauen aber so ist das
projekt minecraft 1 luca hat nun mal
wir nehmen uns oft sachen vor und die
kann man nicht richtig umgesetzt was
damals passiert ich fand die folge sehr
cool menge passiert wir sehen uns
übermorgen wieder hoffentlich dann wenn
wieder zu hause bin
[Musik]